[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday I have
an unusually short period of time in
which to shoot and edit this video today
so this one's going to be built for
speed not built for comfort so Hank it
turns out that the hotel at MIT the
hotel I was staying at in Boston is even
more awesome and nerdfighter Lee than
even I knew about for starters a lot of
the light fixtures look like circuit
boards also in the lobby they have a
bunch of robots on display from MIT
artificial intelligence lab not to
mention the fact that the hotel itself
is located the corners of Sydney and
Green Hank it's mom and of course like
any awesome hotel there's a reading room
so I'm sitting in the reading room and
I'm just like reading and then I leave
the reading room to go meet MT Anderson
and on my way out I happen to notice
what the reading room is called
Hank it's the Norbert Wiener room Hank I
don't want to get all fangirl e on you
but I am a huge Norbert Wiener fan he is
my favorite child prodigy of all time
and they named the reading room at the
hotel at MIT after him
yes nerdfighters take it my team like
I'm getting a little bit too excited
about the whole Norbert Weiner thing but
you have to understand I really like
Norbert Weiner Hank I originally became
aware of the existence of Norbert Weiner
when I was researching my second book an
abundance of Katherine's shameless plug
and aside from having what is
unquestionably the greatest nerdfighter
name of all time it turns out that
Norbert Weiner is also made of Awesome
in many other respects Hank the thing
about child prodigies is that as
impressive as they are intellectually as
children they often don't continue that
intellectual growth into adulthood and
in fact many famous child prodigies end
up becoming really miserable solipsistic
adults in fact when Norbert Weiner was a
kid he was in college at Harvard and he
was at Harvard at the same time as
another famous child prodigy named
William James Sidis William James Sidis
was even smarter than Norbert Weiner and
everyone was like man William James
Sidis is going to be like the most
important intellectual figure in the
whole history of the United States I
mean Hank when the guy was 13 he was
lecturing in astrophysics at Harvard but
then when William James Sidis became an
adult he stopped being interested in
astrophysics and he started being read
be really really interested in railroad
traffic signals and then William James
Sidis went on to spend like 30 years
writing this like 8000 page manuscript
that's everything you ever needed to
know about railroad traffic signals all
the while working as a bookkeeper and
then he died alone anyway Norbert Weiner
was totally headed for the William James
Sidis fate accept Norbert Weiner like
rose up out of the ashes of his
childhood genius and actually managed to
become an adult genius he invented the
field of cybernetics and he's this like
hugely important applied mathematician
and I just love him John Green is -
Norbert Wiener as Chris Crocker is -
Britney Spears
I mean seriously Hank if Norbert Wiener
were to rise from the dead and perform
at the MTV Video Awards and everyone
made fun of his performance because he
was socially awkward and everything
I would totally cry one other really
cool thing about Norbert Wiener he
looked a lot like Colonel Sanders
speaking of genius Hank thanks for
sneaking us into the day might be Giants
concert they were as always awesome also
your video yesterday reminded me of all
those months when you were in high
school when you always spoke with a fake
British accent and you kind of acted
like it was your real regular accent
Hank I'll see you tomorrow
PS a quick memo - nerdfighters in or
around Richmond Virginia if the good
Lord is willing and the creek don't rise
I'll see you tomorrow at 7 p.m. at the
University of Richmond where all be
speaking